at the beginning of the film we are
taken to a hectic scene at a prestigious
Hospital many things happen at once as
two professional burglars thongs and
octopus sneakily steal expensive
medication from the inventory meanwhile
the wealthy Leaf Family enjoys the
joyous occasion of its young miss giving
birth to a baby boy just as the baby is
put into the mother's arms it is
snatched up right before her eyes by her
ex-boyfriend the man believes that he
must be the baby's father and is willing
to waste no effort in order to take the
baby for himself half of the hospital
security Force gives Chase to the
ex-boyfriend while the other half is
trying to catch the burglars in the
process of chasing and running away the
two parties intersect trying to escape
from the security the ex-boyfriend is
pushed to a dead end and gets flustered
this causes him to fall off the
escalator and directly hit the ground
many floors below resulting in his
instant death thankfully thong manages
to catch the baby at the last second and
the baby somehow survives while the
guards are distracted by the chaos the
burglars take this chance to escape
their small team of Thieves is made up
of three members the first is known as
the landlord oh I hate him already he is
more of a mastermind behind the team and
opts to cover the logistics of the
robberies more than the Hands-On action
ever since his wife becoming mentally
ill because of the death of their son he
has been saving his earnings in a safe
without spending anything however
recently he lost all of his Savings in a
home burglary the second member is
octopus he is fond of showing off his
wealth and spends all his money on women
in spite of having a wife he regrets
marrying young and is very uncaring of
her daily struggles even when she
reveals that she is pregnant with his
child octopus does not seem to care he
plainly suggests she aborted and returns
back to his new date enjoy the date
octopus I hope you get mck banged the
third and the last member is thongs a
crippling gambling addict who spends his
loot in casinos and other bats after
losing all his money he is still not
deterred and even goes as far as to
borrow large sums from lone sharks his
father disapproves of his lifestyle
which causes many arguments in the
family with thongs and octopus spending
all their money and the landlord losing
his savings the three men grow
increasingly desperate at this time a
burglary job with a high payment falls
into their hands but the landlord is
hesitant to take it because of the risk
however the other two men are overjoyed
and rushed to take on the job without
even hearing what it entails first they
break into a large mansion by expertly
bypassing the security systems the
Mansion belongs to none other than the
Lee family whose child they saved in the
last burglary soon the three men find
themselves standing inside of a nursery
room it slowly Dawn upon thongs that
they are not here to Rob but to kidnap a
baby the request was made by a Triad
boss who believes that the baby is his
grandson thongs is strictly against the
idea as he believes that it is a line
that they must not cross but right now
the three of them are in desperate need
of some quick cash so they cannot let
this opportunity go thongs reluctantly
agrees to continue with the kidnapping
and they successfully take the child
away they want to hand the baby over and
get the job done with as soon as
possible but luck is not in their favor
on the drive back they encounter a
police roadblock while trying to escape
their car crashes downhill with the
police hot on their tails the landlord
is trapped in the wreckage so he urges
his teammates to take the baby and run
seeing as he is not Gravely injured the
two of them Escape while the landlord is
arrested this Begins the burglar's
bizarre journey of trying to care for
the baby they kidnapped as expected
thongs and octopus have no idea how to
raise a child so even the duration of a
few days is filled with many hurdles
they cannot get the baby to stop crying
which which results in an impromptu
singing session where the men perform
ridiculous dance moves surprisingly this
works and they breathe a sigh of relief
but that is not all they must now feed
the baby change his dirty diapers and
figure out how to keep him entertained
they clumsily prepare a bottle of baby
formula and feed the baby while sneaking
in some sips of their own the most
hazardous task proves to be the diaper
changing they struggle to deal with the
stench all the while the baby happily
laughs at their faces is after a few
stressful days they stumble upon a
parenting class hosted by a nurse which
greatly helps them to take proper care
of the baby she does her best to teach
them while lending them a hand when
needed slowly they learn things like how
to maintain the right temperature of the
baby formula and what are the best ways
to put him to sleep a few weeks pass
before they realize that they genuinely
enjoy taking care of the baby and his
presence makes them want to become
better people when thongs takes the baby
along with him for his usual gambling
sessions he know notices that his heart
has started feeling guilty about
gambling to his own surprise he vows to
never set foot inside the gambling Den
again similarly octopus also begins to
regret his harsh treatment of his wife
every time he looks at the infant he is
reminded of how his own wife is pregnant
and contemplates becoming a father on
the other side the Triad boss is angered
to a great degree so much so that he
locks him in inside a giant cold chamber
and lets him freeze to death angered
that he could not find where his
grandson is he then orders another
subordinate to bring the baby to him at
once the gangsters immediately get to
work afraid of being frozen to death
soon they find thongs attending a
parenting class along with octopus the
men think quickly and hand over the baby
to the nurse while they go out to
confront the gangsters the nurse on the
other hand rushes to th's home for the
baby's safety the two go against several
gangsters but thongs and octopus are
experienced Fighters with teamwork and
sharp thinking they manage to evade the
gangsters and rush home somewhere else
the nurse enters the apartment and is
met with lone sharks who are there to
collect debt that thongs owes them they
push their way in and decide to wait for
him to arrive at the same time octopus's
wife also comes knocking not knowing
what to do the nurse invites her in this
starts a massive misunderstanding as she
mistakes the nurse's octopus's mistress
and the baby as his child meanwhile on
the streets below the apartment thongs
is stopped by the police police officer
involved in solving the kidnapping case
thongs goes to Great Lengths in an
attempt to deter the policeman from
following them home but to no avail when
he finally reaches home he Witnesses the
shocking sight of the debt collectors
gangsters and octopus's wife waiting for
him still he keeps his cool and tries to
distract the officer while the gangsters
and Octopus fight for the baby one of
the gangsters tries to steal the baby by
setting him inside a basket and pulling
it up to the roof but octopus is quick
to slip out of the window to stop the
basket after a short tug of war he
finally manages to untie the rope and
save the baby but because of all this
Ruckus the policeman grows aware of the
situation this results in another messy
Affair of the policeman fighting to
arrest thongs while thongs fights off
the officer along with the gangsters
after some back and forth he manages to
escape out the window and joins octopus
the two make a run for it but in the
process the baby stroller gets hooked to
a military vehicle by mistake the large
truck drives away at full speed Towing
along the stroller while the two Panic
thongs quickly hide jaacks a car to
chase the truck while octopus grabs a
lift on a scooter misunderstanding them
as robbers the truck driver increases
his speed and tries to shake them off
after a painstaking amount of effort
octopus finally manages to get a hold of
the stroller but right then the
gangsters suddenly joined the Run they
hit th's car resulting in octopus
falling off and as Revenge thongs also
hits their car this causes a domino
effect of several accidents and crashes
on the highway amidst the chaos thongs
retrieves the baby at last and runs to
seek shelter in his own home as if on QE
the landlord is released from the police
station as soon as he steps out of the
building he is captured and taken to the
Triad boss who demands that he return
the baby the boss even raises the price
to 30 million making the already willing
landlord Overjoyed he quickly meets up
with thongs and octopus and starts
hatching a plan to hand over the baby to
the Triad boss but to his surprise he
notices that his teammates are reluctant
however they soon realize that they are
in no position to refuse the offer thong
is sickly father paid off all his debts
using the Family Savings leaving thongs
with a heavy feeling of guilt and
octopus also wants to give his wife a
better life where she does not have to
struggle to make ends meet so the two of
them desperately need the money a while
later the three men meet up with the
gangsters to exchange the baby in return
for the suitcases full of cash it is
difficult to let go of the child when
they have grown so attached to him but
still they cannot help but watch as the
gangsters take him away the doctors who
are on standby quickly draw the baby's
blood for a DNA test resulting in him
crying pitifully from the pain no amount
of coaxing from The Strangers can make
him calm down as he keeps staring at
thongs and octopus clearly reluctant to
part the two men overcome by their
feelings for the baby throw away the
last bit of hesitation they Rush after
the gangsters and steal the baby back
with no effort while the landlord runs
away with the money octopus and thongs
run to hide inside the boss's private
amusement park through Ferris wheels and
roller coasters they rush headon to many
dangers all in order to protect the
child from the gangsters who are
relentlessly pursuing them at last thong
somehow outruns them and is seconds away
from escaping when the gangsters managed
to capture octopus on being threatened
with his teammate's life thong has no
choice but to surrender the child to the
Triad Boss Next they are brought to the
boss and silently watch as he gently
cradles the baby in his arms even though
the boss might turn out to be the baby's
grandfather thongs is entirely against
him kidnapping the baby from his mother
all this time the boss has not even
considered the possibility of the baby
not being his biological Grand
grandchild but to his utter shock the
DNA test results mention the unthinkable
the baby is not actually his grandchild
in a days he stumbles to the freezing
chamber where he has carefully preserved
the dead body of his son and places the
baby next to him driven mad by the shock
he then goes away to take his medication
leaving the baby inside the freezer in a
great hurry to save the baby thongs and
octopus rush to the chamber but are
thrown off by the gangster soon they are
overpowered and caught by the gangsters
but their will is stronger than any of
their enemies overturning their
situation they break free and manage to
get inside the chamber but it ends up
closing itself behind them now trapped
inside the freezer with no way out they
noticed that the baby has stopped crying
and he is now unconscious but there is
no way to open the door from the inside
why is that anyway they should really
change that about these in a desperate
attempt to warm up the baby they take
off their jackets to w wrap him around
and huddle close together but nothing
seems to be working just when they are
about to lose hope the landlord appears
outside the freezer with the police but
the chamber is locked with a very
complex lock system landlord being an
expert lock picker orders everyone to
cease all the noise and carefully
concentrates on the sound that the lock
makes with great effort he manages to
figure out the combination and opens the
door however it is not time for
celebration as the baby has stopped
breathing and is turning red this movie
is Goofy but now it's dark thongs and
octopus frantically rush outside but
soon realize that they are too far from
any hospital and the only car in the
garage is broken while thongs miserably
tries to get the baby to breathe he
suddenly gets a risky idea with the help
of octopus he quickly makes a makeshift
defibrillator by hooking the car
batteries with some wires and passing
the electricity to his arms suffering
through the intense pain he uses his
hands to pass the electricity to the
baby's chest in an attempt to revive his
Consciousness but even after several
painful tries they are not successful
soon the police and the ambulance reach
the scene and take the baby away while
the men are left to chase after the
ambulance with great desperation unknown
to them their struggle is a success and
the baby's condition has stabilized in
the following scene the police swiftly
catch the trio of burglars along with
the Triad boss and all his minions the
scene skips to a few months later where
the three men are in jail ja however
they feel that they are now better men
than they ever were their relationship
with their families is also steadily
growing Day by Day the movie ends on a
visiting day where the Lee family comes
to visit them along with the baby as a
token of appreciation for saving the
baby's life thongs octopus and the
landlord are offered jobs by the family
to which they all gladly agree and so a
new chapter of their lives as lawful men
begins subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching